all of these shots just remind me in
breakups
like American food and everything else
from America it's just something turned
way up I feel nervous I'm also really
hungover so this is like my worst
nightmare right now let's get really
drunk yeah let's do this
fireball I've heard a lot about this
from a good friend Eugene back in LA
it smells like being red cheering yeah
yeah big red this sounds extreme whiskey
got my alley I can do it here
Cheers be up your alley in a second that
that's pure sex I you can't really taste
the whiskey at all the top of the tongue
all the way down to the anus it kind of
like just invigorates their whole body
if Dana King ever started selling
alcohol it should be this yeah having a
cinnamon doughnut and a fireball shot
parents love it
yeah actually wanted that one right now
yeah dad let's do it
so this is called a [ __ ] or as in
Australia we call it a gobby I kind of
comfortably shot this without without it
getting all over my face like a [ __ ]
it looks and sounds like the kind of
shot you get at a strip club do I open
my mouth and pull the whole thing like
that it's all over my mouth i courtesy
tab would have been nice no that's [ __ ]
I almost like a tiramisu how do you
order that at a pub pretty much like
having an Irish coffee I see myself
having a [ __ ] at home at work maybe
at church this is the pickle back it
looks like you're in like like while
you're drinking and then like while
you're high sorry
[ __ ] that's a bit of a cheeseburger
aftertaste
it's like Ronald McDonald in my mouth
possibly the worst shot I've ever had I
want to speak to the person who first
came up with this
yeah and just why
this is the Alabama Slama got to say
catchy name when you get really close it
smells like dr. pepper you know when
you're in a club and all the alcohols
kind of fuse together on the floor mmm
that's what this smells like
that's a starburst shock I feel like
it's something you would get at like
when you go out to a dinner party weave
like your mum and dad and someone old
like pulls out a really cheesy shot not
as strong as what it's smelt like for me
it tastes like medicine so much that
like I'm associated with sitting in like
a doctor's waiting room no it's healthy
that's medicine is good for you well
done Alabama yeah so this is a lemon
drop
and it sounds like something your
grandmother will give you this looks
good this looks like a lemon [ __ ] has
been compressed and put into a shot it
tastes like a lemon Smirnoff but being
left out in the Sun for about four hours
super sweet I feel refreshed I feel like
I just like lick to the bottom of like a
pinecone model how many of these can you
have before you get diabetes Wow that
daddy's cordial like not straight
cordial watered-down cordial I think if
you serve that with like crushed ice I
mean way to that I'm Fatima lemon drops
after today
popular shots from America are
everything we thought they would be I'm
quite intoxicated that's a good thing I
think Australia really needs to raise
our shrimp game I think the Americans
have a bit of work to do it's these
shots do make America great again and I
love you America you do food and drink
like no one else in the world please let
me leave there I appreciate your effort
please let me leave that for reals